[Música]
el 2020 ha sido un año atípico para
todos pero más aún para quienes se
contagiaron y tuvieron que luchar para
recuperarse del coi 19 soy el mar y
ángulo y en esta emisión de la serie de
france 24 conoceremos testimonios de
varias personas que sobrevivieron a la
enfermedad desde países como francia el
salvador costa rica chile y argentina
algunos de los infectados que lograron
recuperarse del virus nos contaron cómo
fue a lidiar con los síntomas y la
incertidumbre en medio de la pandemia
comenzamos con la historia de cristian
barry un ciudadano francés que asegura
que los efectos del cobi 19 en sus
pulmones lo llevaron incluso a pensar
que no lograría ganar la batalla al
coronavirus
cristian de 50 años es jardinero en una
pequeña comuna al noroeste de parís
piensa haberse contagiado días antes del
confinamiento
con el foso solía ir a trabajar en
transporte público empecé a tener dolor
de estómago como una gastroenteritis con
fiebre y luego sentí como un ataque como
si algo invadiera mis pulmones entonces
se hizo más grande náuseas un cansancio
que me dejaba por el suelo
la segunda semana los síntomas fueron
peores un médico a distancia le explicó
que tenía una forma bastante seria de
kobe 19
es como por oleadas en un momento estás
bien y luego tienes la impresión de que
casi vas a morir te falta el aire te
ahogas y uno se asusta de ducsa llama
las urgencias y le propusieron un
seguimiento a distancia solo las
personas con dificultad respiratoria son
hospitalizadas
la tercera otros síntomas aparecieron en
[Música]
una mañana había un filtro azul y pensé
que es que me pasa está en mis ojos en
mi cerebro entonces sentí que me iba a
desmayar y pensé que no volvería a ver a
mi hija que está en mexico
me mire en el espejo y comencé a
insultarme insultar a esta enfermedad
finalmente eso me hizo sentir mejor
la enfermedad sigue siendo desconocida
incluso para los científicos
por eso los casos graves pero poco
publicitados como los de christian
sorprenden a familiares y amigos incluso
mi compañera no entendía lo que estaba
pasando conocemos la gripe la
gastroenteritis luego vemos en la
televisión hay personas que se recuperan
en 15 días y luego son felices 40 días
después cristian no se siente
completamente recuperado se hace esto da
la impresión de que con el tiempo el
virus se desvanece tengo ataques más
espaciados que duran dos o tres horas
aún así es infernal no hay que hacerse
el listillo realmente debemos tener
cuidado con lo que hacemos desde nuestro
reportaje se somete cada dos días a
sesiones de kinesiología porque sus
pulmones están dañados desde el salvador
la enfermera veronica portillo nos
cuenta cómo lo que más le preocupaba era
no poder volver a ver a sus hijos la
noche en la que fue notificada de su
contagio fue trasladada a un hospital y
apenas tuvo tiempo para despedirse de
sus pequeños y pedirle que permanecieran
resguardados tras experimentar esta
drástica medida esta madre nos contó
cómo logró recuperarse
mi nombre es verónica alejandra portillo
tengo 31 años soy técnico en enfermería
y labora en las unidades móviles de
fosalud pues creemos que fue a contagio
de alguna compañera que estaba así
entonces abel el hecho de de estar en el
turno con ella en algún momento que nos
bajamos mascarilla fue como para
comernos era quitar entonces en algún
momento fue el contagio fue positivo
porque vinieron a mi casa y tocaron la
puerta y me dijeron que me esperara y
luego vino regreso a los 20 un tal
policía y me dijo mire su prueba salió
positiva su prueba de kobe salió
positiva entonces ya venían los médicos
todavía con el traje especial para
trasladarlo y me dice me voy a llevar a
sus hijos yo quedé en shock entonces
estaba con todos y con cansancio yo lo
había visto en pacientes el distrés
respiratorio pero no es como que no le
llega aire o sea por ningún lado y
entonces empieza
a hacer esto porque quiere agarrar ahí
entonces es desesperante
en ese momento solo quisiera uno que le
pusieran algo para respirar bien
las doctoras me desean desde afuera
verdad y creo que nos ayuda porque para
ello es implicado tratarse 20 minutos en
ponerse el traje y entrar entonces yo lo
que hacía era estar pendiente de los
pacientes ya siendo paciente yo estar
pendiente de los pacientes que tuvieran
el oxígeno y creo que la discriminación
de la población para el personal de
salud es bastante grande aquí no lo ven
como como de héroes que le dicen en otro
país aquí no aquí lo ven a uno con
uniforme mejor se apartan y quisiera
volver a eso
ayudarles ahora que yo ya lo viví
quisiera estar con los más críticos y me
dicen no vas a aguantar el traje no
importa
ya lo pasé
vamos a costa rica porque aunque este
país figura como el de menor índice de
letalidad por ccoo y 19 en latinoamérica
algunos de los que se han contagiado la
enfermedad esta patología los llevó
incluso al estado de coma
uno de ellos fue oscar zamora quien nos
cuenta cómo salió victorioso del
hospital pese a ser considerado como un
paciente de alto riesgo este es su
testimonio
yo estaba en turismo desde hace
muchísimos años andaba con un grupo de
franceses de los cuales dos turistas
tenían el codi 19 no lo sabían ellos
obviamente lo vi en las noticias toda
mucha gente se el virus se le quedan la
garganta y realmente en cuenta sean pero
como yo soy paciente de alto riesgo
porque ser diabético y presión alta
empezó a métodos muchísimo a todos y
fiebre y diarrea
y dolor de huesos que me falta la
respiración
entonces tú y quiero al hospital los
doctores me llamaron a parte miguel de
buscar un izquierdo lo es tan negro
negro está inflamado está lleno de agua
este es el momento de ventilar estoy en
estado de coma durante nueve días por
unos segundos calor corazón en estado
crítico el sexto días puede el estar
internado ya nos decían que no había
empeorado y que ya eso era mucho
entonces ahí como que empezamos a
alegrarnos ya tener más esperanza y fe y
hundió llegó en la mañana como tipo seis
de la mañana me despertó misiones
caserío negativa te voy a mandar para
casa yo ese día lloré y la felicidad
quería hacer un homenaje pero por
supuesto yo le dije no lo mira y todo
caso suyo todo el equipo del cod y 19
que hay en herencia
todos los enfermeros y enfermeras
lloramos
de alegría claro yo también que reciben
muy lindo
[Música]
gracias a dios el hospital que atendió a
mi papá era el único paciente que tenían
y se pudieron dedicar 100% a ellos pero
si esto colapsara tal vez la historia
sería diferente y yo a veces pienso que
es una pesadilla algo que es increíble a
veces uno no lo cree que está pasando
ver todas las personas que están
falleciendo y en chile- hablamos con
sebastián godoy el profesor de 39 años
que se convirtió en el primer contagiado
en ser puesto en cuarentena en el país
un paciente que jamás se imaginó que
alguien como a él sin comorbilidades el
virus lo llevara a debatirse entre la
vida y la muerte
me dicen que estoy contagiado de kobe
que no es una influencia yo me llevo
como en el shock como diciendo como yo
voy al narco y cuando vengo confirman yo
estoy dentro de los primeros 40
diagnosticado decaimiento como inmediato
desde el lunes hacia el martes ya era
cansancio
muy grande a nivel de móvil ya con un
poquito de dificultad de respirar y
moleste a nivel
de garganta como con una tos tipo como
muy seca esta segunda vez y en esa
urgencia lo que
lo que bien es que tenía comprometidos
los dos pulmones que está
grave que pasó a la unidad paciente
crítico y mean to and ese mismo día
porque la gran diferencia del comité o
desde mi experiencia es que también te
deja en una soledad absoluta de sus
familias
de estos 51 días sin ver a mi hijo
en un niño de un año ocho meses
cuando desperté y lo pude ver
deseas más palabras tenía lenguaje
comprensivo y expresivo mucho más claro
como no es tan solo lo que hace es
preguntar qué pasó y es así o sea qué es
lo que pasó que me pasó y uno tiene
evidencia física si éste como enguera
con pinchazos con catéter con pantallas
y en ese pensar si es básicamente
robando esas palabras es un es como una
película de terror son personal de salud
se transforman en tus amigos va a servir
casi tus referentes más cercanos en ese
proceso de ir mejorando ellos fueron muy
importantes cuando yo estaba
en el coma me ponía en la música que me
gustaba me hablaban de mi hijo me
tomaban la mano es como dice violeta
parra gracias a la vida
y ese gracias a la vida que me ha dado
tanto que tengo la oportunidad que
necesitaban
[Aplausos]
y terminamos con la historia de marisol
sanromán una estudiante de postgrado que
se encontraba en españa' y alcanzó a
retornar a su país natal argentina antes
del cierre de fronteras por el inicio de
la pandemia con 25 años esta mujer que
logró recuperarse del virus nos muestra
otra cara de la moneda la de ser
discriminada por contagiarse
yo no creía tener con una virus o pensé
que no pasaba nada que no iba a tener
que va a ser nada más un susto fue todo
muy nuevo para mí estar en un hospital
estar lejos de mi familia lejos de mis
amigos
hola a todos mi nombre es marisol
sanromán tengo 25 años y me
diagnosticaron cobit 19 positivo es
decir tengo coronavirus ese vídeo paso
por todos lados
en el momento donde más dolor sentía más
angustia más desesperación yo pensé que
iba
a recibir algún mensaje de recuperar te
va a estar todo bien sin embargo me
decepcione me encontré por primera vez
en mi vida
con discriminación y con acoso
gente diciendo que ojalá me muera
que porque había regresado argentina que
se había traído el virus diciéndome
cosas horribles un día recibe una
amenaza
alguien me dijo que sabía que estaba
dentro de mi cuarto en el momento que yo
estaba mirando la ventana
y me dijo que se va a encargar de que no
respire nunca más se llame asusté
muchísimo por eso decidí denunciado y se
la primera denuncia por acoso por
ciberacoso por coronavirus agravado por
violencia de género aprendí mucho en
todo este tiempo y sufrí mucho también
porque fue todo muy doloroso yo no sabía
hacia el día siguiente me iba a levantar
no sabía qué iba a pasar conmigo
y es por eso que
se paran es tan importante que la gente
se cuide que se laven las manos que usen
barbijos tapabocas que se queden en sus
casas porque nos quieren pasar lo que
pase yo con esa historia llegamos al
final de esta serie dedicada a los
recuperados del cob y 19 testimonios de
pacientes que luego de ganar en la
batalla de la enfermedad nos recuerdan
la importancia de mantener las
precauciones sigan aquí con más estos
france24
[Música]